So now let's we got a couple more
references. We're going to wrap it up.
Hopefully I'll talk to you more because
if you're honest to God, you're going to
give up on your Judaism and stop joining
Muslims bashing Christians less we bash
you in return. I want you to go to
Exodus 24 9-11.
>> One moment. Exodus 24 9-11.
>> Yes.
>> All right.
Sorry. and Moses and and
70 of the elders of the elders of Israel
ascended and they perceived God of
Israel and beneath his feet was like the
forming of a sapphire brick.
>> They did what with the God of Israel
>> beneath and they perceived the God of
Israel but beneath his feet.
>> So your God has feet, huh?
>> Well, no, not necessarily.
You notice what you've been doing? I'm I
want you go back and play this. No, not
necessarily. No, not necessarily.
>> Not necessarily. I know. I said I don't.
>> Okay, but you'll see. Read the text
carefully. It says there was something
visible under his feet, a pavement that
looked like sapphire. So, were they
hallucinating? So, your god was like
hallucinating to them.
>> It says they saw what looked like a
paved work of sapphire under his feet.
But then keep reading to 11.
>> And upon his nobles of the children of
is sorry, upon the nobles of the
children of Israel, he did not lay his
hand. And they perceived God and they
ate and drank.
>> They did what? Now I like your
translation says perceive. How
beautiful. You can you admit, please
don't tap dance. That that word verb can
mean see, not just perceive as your
translation translated it.
>> Of course. I I admit that completely.
>> Okay. So you admit it can mean they saw
God, right?
>> Mhm.
>> Okay.
>> So Well, hold on. Not that they saw God
as like his literal essence behind the
>> Nobody sees God's essence.
>> We all agree. say, "Well, I mean, you
would have said his essence because you
believe that God is manifesting himself
on earth because that's different from
the tri."
>> You're confused. You're confused. Even
Jesus manifesting on earth, we're not
seeing the full essence of God because
the essence of God is invisible. That's
why he appears visibly in various forms
because God's essence is invisible. So,
learn trinitarian theology properly. But
besides that, can God appear visibly in
a form even in a human form even though
that form is not his essence per se
because God's essence is invisible? Can
God do that?
>> Well, would it be do you believe that uh
if he did right do you believe that it
would be his essence behind the curtain?
>> What are they saying if it's not God's
essence behind the curtain? So God what?
It's just some trick form that it's not
nothing connected to God. So when they
say, "Oh, that's God." And God is
saying, "Haha, that's not me. I'm just
projecting an image over there." Really?
>> Go to Isaiah 6 is the final one because
I have to We'll talk more. I'll contact
you this week, God willing. Go to Isaiah
6 105.
>> Isaiah 6 105.
[Music]
Read it slowly for a minute. I got to
confess you. I don't want to be too
long. Go right. Isaiah 6 105.
>> In the year of death of king of king,
I saw the Lord sitting on a high and
exalted throne, his lower extremity.
>> Slowly I saw Adonai. Saw I'm glad your
translation didn't translate it as
perceive. I saw Adonai on what?
>> Meaning on the throne and exalted on the
throne. So he's seeing a throne and he's
seeing Adonai in a visible shape sitting
on a throne and he has a robe. Keep
reading.
>> Mhm.
>> Which are
stood above stood above him. Six wings.
Six wings to each one. Uh with two he
would cover his face and with two he
would cover his feet and with two he
would fly.
>> Keep wrong. All the way to five.
>> Oh, sorry. And one called to other And
one called to other he said, "Holy,
holy, holy is the Lord of hosts. The
whole earth is full of his glory."
>> Okay. Now read verse 5. What does it
say?
>> Let's just verse three. So verse five.
Yeah.
>> And the doorpost quake uh from the voice
of him who called and the house became
filled with smoke.
>> And I said, and this is verse five. And
I said, uh, woe is me for I am lost for
I am a man of unclean lips and amidst
the people of unclean lips I lips I
dwell. Uh, for the king, the Lord of
hosts, have my eyes seen.
>> Wow. Let me hammer it so it sinks in.
My eyes, these physical eyeballs, my
physical eyes have seen the Lord of
Hosts, the King. My physical eyeballs.
Why does Isaiah not sound like your
rabbis? Isaiah said, "Unlike your rabbis
and you," wow,
I'm an unworthy man, but I have seen
with my physical eyeballs the Lord
himself, not some intermediate, on the
throne and the seraraphim worshiping
him, Hashem. Wow. But now I want to put
the icing on the cake for you. Go back
to Isaiah 6:1. He saw him on a throne.
And the throne is what? High and lifted
up, right?
Yes.
>> Okay. High and lift it up. Right.
>> Mhm.
>> Go to Isaiah 5. Okay. But remember the
words. It's Ram and Ram and Nissa. Go to
Isaiah 52:13 for me.
Isaiah 52:13. For me, the servant that
you say is Israel, which is good. I'm
not going to argue whether it's Messiah
Mashiach or not. We'll go with Israel.
Isaiah 52:13.
Thank you. And it says, "Behold, my
servant shall prosper. He shall be
exalted and lifted up and he shall be
very high."
>> Okay. Now, can you confirm the words
exalted and lifted up are the same two
verbs used in Isaiah 6:1?
>> Yes.
And another one it is.
>> Okay. Now, I want you I'm going to
challenge you to find to prove me wrong
when you come text me on Skype. I want
you to show me where those verbs are
used for anyone other than God in his
exaltation. So my challenge to you is
what in the world is doing saying that
the servant is exalted to the status of
God? Because the words high and lifted
up, those words are only used of God and
used of God on his throne. Why is the
servant exalted to the position of God
if he's just a creature?
No, this has actually been a debate in
the Talmud by Rabi.
>> Say it again. It's been a what?
>> A debate in the Talmud. By
it was between the Rabaka and the
school, the academy that he was a part
of. And he basically said,
>> right, regarding this verse and another
verse in the Psalms
>> Y
>> uh where basically the throne is right
>> and I believe you know the the whole two
thrones in heaven controversy.
>> Yeah, that's a Daniel 7. Daniel 7. I
know they were he said one from Messiah,
one for God and David and then they said
no, one for mercy and justice. I'm aware
of the toic.
>> Okay, but here's the problem with thatic
reference.
>> I don't care what the tomud says. The
text doesn't say one for justice and one
for mercy because in Isaiah 52, it's the
servant being exalted to the status of
God. And Daniel 7, it's the ancient of
days and the son of man. It's not
justice and mercy. But my question to
you, and I know you don't believe Jesus
Messiah, okay? You believe the servant
is Israel. So, Israel is exalted. Now,
all I want you to do is all I want you
to do is tell me with I know you don't
believe in Jesus Messiah. That's okay.
>> Why are Christians wrong for believing
that Jesus who's an Israelite and if the
servant is Israel, the nation, and the
nation will be exalted to the status of
God? Why would you accuse us of
blasphemy and saying that this Jesus,
the Israelite, who would be part of that
servant, the nation Israel, has been
exalted to God's status. When that's
what you find Isaiah 52:13 saying about
the servant, the servant
>> doesn't say to God's status.
>> Yes, it does. It says high and lifted
up.
>> It does not say to God's status.
>> Okay, hold on. Wait. I want to give you
the
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Saying that because it says, right,
which is, you know, most people, you
know, right? Yeah,
>> this is not it does not exactly say to
his status. This is not the same status
as God, right? It doesn't have to be the
same status as God. In fact, it does not
does not say he will be exalted on the
same level of does not say that.
>> Now, the thing is saying simply because
uh these you know these two words are
only ascribed to God. If they are, I'm
not sure. I will check for you. However,
>> it is not saying that this is the same
status as God. It's simply saying that
he shall be exalted and lifted up. These
this is the literal meaning of those two
words. It simply means that this the
nation of Israel will be exalted and
lift up. And listen, we are described as
you know the light to the Gentiles. We
are described you know as the
consistently most pious nation etc. And
you know as an example for you know the
non-Jews and for you know those who you
know you know people who are right
worshippers of the for worship of the
stars etc are to follow. Now,
>> now you know I let you just keep
speaking because you know you're not
saying anything and I'm going to refute
you now, right?
>> That it is the same as status of God.
Are you ready now?
>> Okay. Because see, I just let because if
I cut you off, you're going to say, "Ah,
I'm cutting you off." Okay. You just
told everyone I want everyone to hear.
You just said it's not the same status
of God. Now, I want you to read Isaiah
52:13 for me one more time.
>> Behold, my servant shall prosper. He
shall be exalted and lifted up, and he
shall be very high.
>> Okay? Now very high. Now when it says
exalted and what in your translation cuz
I don't know what translation you're
reading.
>> Exalted lifted up.
>> Okay. Now exalted and lifted up. Right.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. Now go to Isaiah 6 vers1.
>> It says the same words. I know.
>> Same words. Now go do me a favor. Go now
to Isaiah 33:10.
And I'm going to read to you what Rabbi
Moshe Cohen Iban Chrisen said about
Isaiah 52:3. I'm going to read your own
rabbi. Okay?
>> Because I'm going to end it with your
own rabbi to show that you're wrong. I'm
right because I I agree with the rabbi.
Okay? Now Isaiah 53.
>> I will rise, says the Lord, and I'll be
raised and I will be exalted.
>> Okay? Now, when it says I'll be raised
and I will be exalted, is that that not
the same verb verbs used in Isaiah
52:13?
>> Yes, of course.
>> Wait, wait. So wait, your God is going
to be exalted and lifted up. Why is he
going to be exalted and lifted up? and
exalt and lift it up to where
>> it's not necessarily literal is
essentially he will be whatever he will
say for example
right and it says and then it says you
know right it the thing is right this
doesn't necessarily say when it says you
know I will be exalted I'll be lifted up
essentially saying I will be praised
right I'll be appraised by the nations
>> and what makes him
>> his exalted status over creation right
>> and that's symbolized by what what
symboliz izes his status over the
nations, his throne in heaven. Say it
again.
>> Mhm. A throne.
>> Okay. Oh, but hold on. When the same
verbs are used of the servant, you don't
want me to believe he's being exalted to
the status of God, even though those
verbs are only used of God and no one
else besides the servant. But you still
don't want me to believe that because
your rabbitic tradition blinds you to
allowing the scripture to say what it
says. Can you read Isaiah 57:15?
>> Isaiah 57:15.
Mhm.
Hold on. Let me see.
>> For the so high and exalted one who
dwells to eternity, and his name is
holy. With the lofty and the holy ones I
dwell.
>> Hey, slowly, slowly, man. You're going
too fast, dude. Calm down. Read it
again. Isaiah 57. With the lofty with
the lofty and holy ones I dwell and with
the crushed and humble in spirit to
revive the spirit as to revive the
spirit of the humble and survive the
heart of the crushed.
>> Okay. Now your translation translated
plural. I said you I can see why you
said the kabad is bad. Okay. It says for
thus says the high and lofty one. Can
you confirm when it says high and lofty
one? Those are the same two verbs used
in Isaiah 52:13.
>> Oh, let me see. Hold on.
>> Read it again. Isaiah 57:13. Wait, so
who's the high and lofty one
>> here?
>> Okay. But in Isaiah 52:13, who's going
to be the high and lofty one?
>> Israel.
>> Say it again.
>> So wait, Hashem is high and lofty and
his throne is high and lofty. And then
Israel is going to be high and lofty.
And those words are only used of God and
his status. And you still want to
convince me it doesn't mean that the
servant will be exalted to the status of
God. Yeah, I'm convinced. But now, can I
read to you what the rabbi says? Now,
you don't have to agree with him. I
don't It's okay. Rabbi Mosh,
>> can you show me? Well, hold on. Can I
Can you show me where Chrisin says this
as well?
>> Yeah, I'm going to show I'm about to
read it. Rabbi Moshe Cohen Iben Krispen.
Okay. And I'll get you the quote. Okay.
It's a long quote. Are you okay with me
reading it?
>> Yes, of course.
>> And I'll give you the link to my
article. This is his exposition of
Isaiah 52:13. Says, "I will now proceed
to my exposition. Behold, my servant
shall have understanding from the
prophets saying understanding. It may be
seen that all the lofty predicates which
he assigns to him have their source in
this attribute in v view v in virtue of
his comprehensive intelligence. He will
attain an elevation above that even of
the most perfect men in the world. He
shall be high and exalted and lofty
exceedingly according to the midrash of
our rabbis. He'll be higher than Abraham
who was first of all a high father and
afterwards a father of multitude. He'll
be more exalted than Moses who was
exalted above the exalted ones of Levi
>> who was a prophet such that none arose
like him in Israel
>> who saved Israel to great salvation when
they came out of Egypt. and the report
of whom spread to all places until the
dukes of Edom were confounded before
him. And trembling seas the mighty men
of Moab and all the inhabitants of
Canaan melted away. Now pay attention to
this. But this one will be exalted far
above Moses. For when he gathers
together our scattered ones, gathers
together our scattered ones from the
four corners of the earth, he will be
exalted in the eyes of all the kings in
the whole world. and all of them will
serve him and will exalt him above them.
As Daniel prophesies concerning him, all
nations, peoples, and tongues shall
serve him. Now, pay attention. He quoted
Daniel about the son of man and applied
it to this one. He says, "As Daniel
prophesied about him." Now, watch what
he says about this one. He'll be loftier
than Solomon, whose dignity was so lofty
that he is said to have sat on the
throne of the Lord. And our rabbis say
that he was king over both the upper and
the netherworld. But the king Messiah
Malik Mashiach and is all comprehending
intelligence will be loftier than
Solomon. And you told me it's Israel.
Okay. But now let's keep reading.
>> Exceedingly above the ministering
angels. He's even going to be higher
than the angels because that same
comprehensive intelligence will approach
God. Pay attention to this. will
approach God more nearly nearly than
theirs. For it is an exceedingly high
privilege that one whose nature is
compound and material because he's human
should attain to a grade of intelligence
more nearly divine
than that which belongs to the
incorporeal meaning angels. And so it is
said of him that his strength is greater
than that of the ministering angels
because these have no impediment in the
exercise of their intellect. Whereas
that which is compound is continually
impeded in consequence of material
element in its nature. Now watch, it's
going to get better for you, my friend.
Accordingly, the great of his
intelligence being such as this, he is
set to be lofty exceedingly and his
strength to be greater than the angels.
And when this servant of the Lord is
born, he will continue to be marked by
the possession of intelligence, enabling
him to acquire from God what is
impossible
what is impossible for any to acquire
until he reaches the height whether none
of the sons of men except him have ever
ascended. No son of man has attained
this height except him who ascended
there. From that day he will be counted
with his people Israel and will share
their subjugation and distress in all
their affliction. He will be exceedingly
afflicted because of their being outcast
and scattered to the ends of the world.
His grief will be such that the color of
his countenance will be changed from
that of a man and pains and sicknesses
will seize him. I'm almost done. For
great grief, as physicians know, by
producing melancholy subjects a man to
many diseases, and all the chastisements
which come upon him in consequence of
his grief, will be for our sakes. Now
watch, and not from any deficiency or
sin on his part, which might bring
punishment and strain, because he is
perfect in the completeness of
perfection, as Isaiah says, truly all
his pains and sicknesses will be for us.
Do you agree with the rabbi?
No, I mean not necessarily. I disagree.